talk about the summer movie season we've
already seen some huge blockbusters
including top gun maverick the first
movie of the year to cross the one
billion dollar mark for ticket sales the
sequel marks tom cruise's highest
grossing film of all time of course need
to mention that it is distributed by
paramount pictures which is a division
of our parent company top gun isn't the
only high profile summer release you got
movies like where the crawdads sing
nope and bullet train they will all be
hitting the theaters in just a few weeks
so joining us now is eric davis managing
editor at fandango eric my friend always
good to see you always on fourth of july
talk about movies here at cbs mornings
um so there are a lot of really cool
films coming out including really
excited for this reese witherspoon is
doing a film adaptation of where the
crawdads uh sing what can you tell us
about that yeah i mean we all know this
book it is one of the best-selling books
of all time by delia owens and it is
part courtroom drama part romantic drama
about a girl who she's abandoned when
she's a young girl she grows up in the
marshlands of north carolina uh and then
she's accused of murdering a boy she
gets involved with uh so yeah it's it's
got a little bit of drama a little bit
of thrills some romance definitely some
romance keep an eye on the star daisy
edgar jones okay i think she's a rising
star i think she's destined to go on to
do big things also in a film earlier
this year called fresh which i really
like if you're a harvest i mean i know
everybody loves dealing that book de
leon's book uh where the quad sing was a
huge huge blockbuster um so and it's
reese witherspoon yeah i mean she
delivers every time she does a great job
of finding these books and turning them
into into really entertaining movies
yeah i saw you looking over at me when
you said romance but what you don't know
about me she does i like it dark she is
a dark she is super she's not a romance
film goer brings me to i'm the rom-com
guy and she's like the darker the better
which brings me to nope
jordan peels next thriller and i've been
analyzing the thriller right trying to
figure out exactly it's an alien flick
sort of but i i can't get a full grasp
of what it's about yeah nobody really
can and of everything that's coming out
the rest of the summer this is my most
anticipated i'm a big fan of jordan
peele's first two films get out and us
and here he re-teams with his get out
star daniel kaluuya and he builds it as
the great american ufo story when we
interviewed jordan peele he said on the
title he says it's meant to reflect what
he hopes audiences are yelling out at
the screen during certain moments of the
film he wants people saying no
not for me
that's hilarious but it looks great and
jordan peele always gives you a film
that's worth talking about afterwards
too and so i'm curious to see some of
the themes in this film it's his biggest
film to date as long as they're not
yelling another four-letter word
um the only chance i have of getting
into a theater this summer is probably
with kids
can you talk about this super pets
you walk times square and like every
block there's a there's a billboard with
it yeah well
i mean we know families are back at the
movies right minions opened up it had
the greatest july 4th weekend ever at
the box office and so dc super pets will
be the next one what if the justice
league was captured
who was going to save them right it's
the patrick
crypto
and it's inspired by pets and pets too
right it's like in the same
yeah well yeah the not the secret life
of pets that's a completely different
film although kevin hart does star as a
dog and both
but yeah dwayne johnson kevin hart he's
got a really great cast john krasinski
is also he plays superman in it and it's
just a really fun funny movie that sort
of a lighter version of dc uh and if
you're a pet fan i think you're gonna
really have a good time ed listen i've
been using my daughter to see these
movies for a long time i'm kind of aging
out of it now she's like 11.
don't use their kids as an excuse you
can go with them
i'm going to go see super pass
and i'm also going to go see thor
love and thunder
can't wait for this latest entry in the
mcu what do you know well chris
hemsworth does something that no other
marvel cinematic universe hero has done
with this film it's his fourth solo
movie we haven't seen right four movies
from a hero but really it's the second
since the character was refashioned by
writer director taika watidi into being
more humorous more absurd it's the
version of thor that i like something to
know about this film natalie portman
returns to the franchise of to play
mighty thor and then christian bale and
russell crowe enter the mcu and very
memorable performances from both this is
thrown off by the trailer why because i
was like is this a comedy because it
kind of involves it you didn't see that
you didn't see the first century
oh well you got to go see that emery and
then come back and talk to us at the
table um it looks really really good and
natalie portman i i think that it's
really cool that they're actually
promoting her because normally it's like
a surprise but it's not she's like front
and center oh yeah well and taika watiti
wanted to kind of refashion natalie
portman's character the way he did thor
in thor ragnarok so this is a different
version of the character she becomes a
thor uh superhero as well and there's
definitely a tragic kind of storyline
there for her character if you know the
comics you know where i'm going with
that but i won't spoil it but i had a
really good time with it and i would
recommend it have you seen elvis you
guys have you seen albus yeah but you've
seen elvis no no no no no i don't i work
with you every day you're gonna talk to
me every day about every detail i don't
have to see them
i have you
you don't have to tell america that i
bother you every day
it's doing great it's doing great it's
over 100 million worldwide wow i think
it's going to be nominated for oscars i
think austin butler will be nominated
for best actor oscar doing fantastic and
a really great film for adults if you're
looking for something that's not
kid-friendly or [ __ ] ed all right okay
okay okay eric thank you so much